these are the animals all others fear
the apex predators
the top hunters in their realm
the killers no nearby animal would dare
to challenge
these are the world's deadliest
[Music]
the ultimate predators
in the world of hunters one apex
predator is legendary for efficiency
the great white shark
it seems evolution has created the
ultimate killer
this is one of the most lethal sharks on
earth
one that all other animals steer clear
of
but even this top predator misses more
than it catches
along the coast of south africa
a great white shark is on the prowl
here there are roughly 1 000 fur seals
for every great white
[Music]
at over 100 pounds an adult fur seal
could be a good meal for a shark
but a seal that's grown this big has
learned ways to avoid great
whites
the younger seals aren't nearly so wise
and the shark could almost catch them at
will
[Music]
but seal pups are too small to keep this
shark satisfied for long
because at more than 20 feet in two tons
there's a lot of great white to feed
great whites have excellent eyesight
both underwater and above
they are the only known fish species
that will spy hop or stick their heads
out of the water to see what's on the
surface
[Music]
site is so important to a great white
then in the last seconds of an attack it
rolls its eyes back into its head to
protect them
many great whites have scars around
their eyes from seal bites
the older seals know what's waiting for
the younger and unlucky
but they need to reach deeper waters to
fish
[Music]
but the shark has more than speed good
eyesight and surprise on its side
it can hear extremely well and can
detect motion from over a mile away
its face is covered with jelly filled
pouches that are so sensitive to
electric fields it can detect muscle
movement and heartbeats
if there's a seal in the water near it
the shark will almost always sense its
presence
lying in weight
rushing up at 25 miles per hour
the other seals flee but they can't
relax for long
this meal will only hold the shark for
two days
then it will be back and the hunt will
start all over again
the great white brings multiple weapons
to a fight
[Music]
while other predators rise to the top by
specializing
[Music]
south america's jungles have their own
versions of water-bound terror
but only one group the constrictors
uses sheer muscle power to become the
apex predator
they literally squeeze prey to death
and the largest and most muscular of the
constrictors
south america's green anaconda
this is one of the most massive snakes
on earth
it weighs over 200 pounds and measures
close to 20 feet long
the anaconda shares this flooded plane
with the capabara
the largest rodents on earth
often reaching more than 100 pounds
capabara are social animals and
herbivores
much of their diet consists of aquatic
plants so they spend a lot of time near
water
prime hunting ground for the anaconda
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
under water it can stalk without being
seen poking its head up just long enough
to gauge the distance
[Music]
then it waits
lying in ambush
the capabara stays within range
the anaconda strikes latching on with
six rows of teeth coiling itself around
the large rodent
every time the copper bar exhales
the anaconda tightens its grip
it constricts the blood flow to the
copper barra's heart causing cardiac
arrest
the anaconda can't tear its prey apart
so it has to somehow fit the entire four
foot meal into its stomach at one time
its lower jaw is not fused to its skull
the jaw separates in the middle and
flexible ligaments permit the jaw to
open extra wide
the remarkably elastic jaw and teeth
that bend backward allow the anaconda to
engulf its prey in one gigantic bite
it's a huge meal
the anaconda will rest digesting its
catch for more than two weeks
a cup of bar this size will satisfy it
for months but eventually it will need
to feed again
and nothing will be safe from the
ultimate death squeeze
the anaconda's mammoth coils may give us
nightmares but the australian dingo
looks like the family pet
[Music]
it seems too cute and cuddly to be
deadly
but don't be fooled
this is australia's top predator
dingoes were domesticated dogs when they
arrived here aboard traders canoes about
five thousand years ago
but they escaped their owners and
returned to the wild
ever since they've thrived across the
entire continent
with no real rivals at the top of the
food chain
[Music]
they're so successful they strike fear
into australia's largest animals like
the grey kangaroo
[Music]
[Applause]
almost nothing not even the fastest
animal can escape them for long
but this relentless hunter is also a
doting caregiver
there's a new litter and everything is
given over to the young including the
hunter's most recent meal
[Music]
for a youngster any animal like an
echidna is something to poke prod and
nibble to see how it tastes
sharp spines protect it from becoming
just another chew toy
a dingo becomes most lethal when it
teams up with others
as they get older the pups learn to work
in tandem
spotting a monitor lizard on the beach
two siblings have a new unwilling
playmate
[Applause]
finally the monitor gets far enough to
submerge and the puppies are reluctant
to follow
by the time they're mature dingos like
all predators go after prey that put up
the least resistance
domesticated sheep and cattle are like
dingo fast food
the dingo's prowess has earned them the
wrath of ranchers who see them as pests
their aggression isn't limited to prey
dingoes work out a hierarchy through
intimidation and the occasional fight
this way each dog knows his or her role
when it comes to the hunt
[Music]
they need to work as a team to bring
down prey as big and powerful as a grey
kangaroo
kangaroos can weigh over 145 pounds and
hop at speeds of up to 45 miles per hour
[Music]
to wear one down the dingos take turns
chasing it
[Music]
working in relays
[Music]
there's little time to celebrate
every dog needs to eat as quickly as it
can because a pack this big can devour
an entire kangaroo in a matter of
minutes
for dingoes it's all about the family
unit
[Music]
this is where life's lessons are passed
from one generation to the next
[Music]
the ability to teach and learn is what
separates some apex predators from the
rest of the pack
[Music]
for a grizzly bear cub the lessons
started day one
and the best teacher is mom
late spring in yellowstone park
for elk it's calving time
newborn calves follow their mothers
around intently learning what they need
to know to survive
[Music]
for grizzly bears the elk calving time
is dinner time
and the sight of a vulnerable young calf
is hard to resist
when she gets lucky and close enough to
a calf she can take off in a quick burst
and chase it down
[Music]
grizzly bears can and will eat just
about anything
most of their diet isn't even meat
they've developed grinding teeth in the
back to chew tough plants
[Music]
long claws to dig up insects and roots
and even shellfish
a grizzly is on the prowl constantly
searching for any food
digging
grazing
scavenging
[Music]
the strong stomach is just part of what
makes this bear an apex predator
size is a factor
this grizzly is almost one thousand
pounds
and where fish is plentiful
its cousins grow even larger
[Music]
when the salmon return to spawn they
fill the rivers and provide a fat rich
bounty for bears
[Applause]
young and old they all gather to fish
the biggest claiming the best spots
and using their bulk and mean tempers to
take what they don't catch
farther inland the bear has to develop
other hunting strategies
today bison could be on the menu they're
twice the size of an average bear no
easy take down
but where there are bison there are
bison babies
the key is to separate the calf from its
mother
[Music]
[Music]
a bear attack is all about speed and
power
but another even more lethal hunter
prefers a game of cat and mouse
in isolated pockets of siberia and india
they are the one hunter of all animals
including humans fear
[Music]
tigers
weighing as much as 600 pounds bringing
in a nasty set of canines and claws to
every encounter
sprinting at 35 miles per hour
but the biggest and most powerful cat on
earth misses far more often than it
kills
because it lacks one key quality
stamina
a large tiger has to get within pouncing
distance of its target otherwise it
tires quickly and has to give up the
chase
to succeed the tiger depends on an
unlikely weapon
its stripes
[Music]
their color and pattern help this one
blend into the grass
[Music]
on silent paws a female moves undetected
through the brush
stealing towards a band of monkeys
[Music]
out of sight she now has to wait for one
to come close enough for a quick strike
[Music]
success
but this monkey is little more than an
appetizer
or a snack to share with her young
the cubs depend on the mother for up to
three years
only half of them will survive that long
and when they do make it staying fed can
be a full-time job
a large tiger needs to eat at least 12
pounds of meat a day
in summer the watering holes begin to
shrink
[Music]
animals crowd around
they're on edge
watching for the hidden menace
[Music]
[Music]
the tiger's challenge is to get as close
as possible
[Music]
[Music]
with a kill that can hold it through the
night
the tiger melts back into the grass
tigers need a huge hunting territory
but another apex predator has learned to
thrive in a relatively tiny range
[Music]
the galapagos islands where life has
evolved in unique ways
[Music]
so
[Music]
here in the galapagos islands the apex
predator isn't a large mammal or even a
reptile
it's a bird
of course this is no ordinary bird
the galapagos hawk is armed with a
vicious beak and a set of talons
with no enemies the galapagos hawks have
their pick of animals to hunt
a favorite meal is another galapagos
oddity
big males stand their ground
too strong for even a hawk
the real hunting opportunity comes when
the iguanas leave the coast
once a year females venture inland to
dig
burrows this is where they lay and bury
their eggs
and for hawks it's a chance to gorge
but the lizards are wearing
their burrows double as hideouts
[Music]
[Music]
even when the hawk sinks its talons into
this iguana the fight isn't over
the lizards are surprisingly powerful
and can wriggle free from the hawk's
grip
[Music]
struggling to reach safety one battles
to reach the water
but it's too late
the real feast is held almost exactly
100 days later however
the hawks gather around the burrows
sensing the approach of dinner
like clockwork young iguanas pop out
but they seem to know something nasty
waits for them if they're not careful
the fate of each hangs on its short legs
good luck and the sheer number of how
many of its siblings and cousins make a
break at the same time
it's a mad one-sided race
[Music]
the hawks gorge themselves on the iguana
hatchlings
the iguana hatch coincides with the
hawk's own
feeding them fresh iguana they raise
another generation with a taste for the
galapagos delicacy
learning their craft can never start too
early for apex predators
but some
are just natural born killers
crocodiles seem to spend their entire
lives with every sense turned towards
the hunt
on a riverbank in east africa
crocs are hatching
the gender of each is determined by the
heat in the
nest if the egg stays between 88 and 90
degrees it produces a male
higher or lower and it produces a female
now they're vulnerable
a quick snack for hungry predators
[Music]
but this is their mother and she's not
eating them she's protecting them
to gently pick up her babies she uses
the deadliest jaws on the planet
they're capable of delivering a bite
force of five thousand pounds per square
inch
which makes them more than seven times
more powerful than a great white sharks
bite
this mother carries a mouthful to safer
waters
even then she has to stand guard
only one percent of newborns make it to
adulthood
this youngster's instinct to kill is
there almost from day one
[Music]
as it grows bigger it moves its way up
the food chain
feathered furred or otherwise all that
matters to the croc is that it's edible
after 20 years it grows to 14 feet long
and weighs 500 pounds
to a crock this big anything that
ventures near a watering hole is a
potential meal
crocodiles can't easily chase down prey
they are ambush hunters that prefer
their prey to come to them
[Applause]
it's feast or family for the crocodiles
so they gorge when food is plentiful
and the biggest meal of the year is
about to arrive
searching for water in green grass
millions of zebras wildebeests and
antelopes join one of the largest mass
migrations on the planet
rivers are one of the few reliable
sources of water
but they are also home to crocodiles
the herd gathers at the river's edge
they're suspicious and the crocs don't
want to scare them off so the crocs lay
low hoping to lure as many into the
river as possible
the croc can stay underwater for up to
two hours at a time
[Music]
it works its way to the edge
[Music]
waiting for the right moment
inches from the kill but it misses
spooking the first row of animals
however there are hundreds of thousands
more that need to cross
the croc just has to retreat and bite
his time
driven by their migration the herd
crosses the river's edge
when the pressure mounts from the herd
pushing from the back the ones in front
are forced into the river
it's like a dam break
and the croc has its pick of prey
it has up to 68 pointed teeth that it
uses to catch and latch onto its prey
but it can't tear and chew its meal
instead it thrashes and spins to rip
apart pieces
then swallows the pieces whole
[Music]
when the rains come and the river isn't
the only source of water easy kills
become rare
but the croc has one more trick
it can slow down its own metabolism so
when food is scarce it can fast for
months
[Music]
[Music]
many top hunters look the part but it's
hard to picture some as ruthless killers
with the leopard seal appearances are
deceiving
this is one of the antarctic's deadliest
hunters
but on the beach an adult seal can
barely roll over let alone pose a
serious threat
[Music]
for the penguins this leopard seal is
little more than a speed bump on their
path to the water
and it's a large barrier at ten feet and
one thousand pounds
but when the seal drops into the water
it's transformed
with a streamlined body and powerful
flippers it can reach speeds of 14 miles
per hour
and turn on a dime
[Music]
the seal looks like an aquatic ballerina
until it opens its mouth to reveal sharp
one-inch canines
[Music]
the seals tactics are pretty simple
swim along the edge of a penguin colony
staying under water and out of sight
[Music]
and there's nothing complicated about
the kill either
it grabs a penguin by the feet and
repeatedly beats it against the surface
the seal literally smashes it to pieces
[Applause]
then it can eat the flesh and the fatty
parts letting the rest float away
[Music]
leopard seals are sloppy killers
compared to one of south america's apex
predators
in murky tributaries of the amazon river
it uses what could be the strangest
hunting tactic of all
[Music]
this six foot long animal produces what
almost no other animal can conjure
a killing shock of electricity
[Music]
known as the electric eel it's a unique
creature more closely related to a
catfish than an eel
[Music]
so
[Music]
first it produces a small electric field
sensing distortions in it to navigate
and to find other animals
these fish have no idea that their
heartbeats and muscle action are drawing
a killer closer
the electric eel probes likely hiding
spots
the eel is not going to rest until it's
eaten
[Music]
sensing prey the eel flushes it out into
the open and delivers its death blow
500 volts enough to stun an adult human
quiet until hunger moves the eel to hunt
again
[Music]
full the eel disappears into the murk
[Music]
at the other extreme of the planet one
hunter is so dominant it never hides and
has nothing to fear
in the eyes of a polar bear everything
looks like lunch
a bear can kill anything it catches but
seal is a favorite meal
the polar bear's keen sense of smell can
detect a seal from a mile away in under
three feet of snow
seals use air holes in the ice where
they can breathe
and a bear can follow the scent of the
seal's breath
the bear waits until the seal surfaces
and pounces
seals also build dens under the snow and
once the polar bear locates the den it
smashes in the roof and pulls out its
meal
the bear is so successful in this short
period it often grows a white shadow
an arctic fox
it follows the bear everywhere feasting
on the leftovers
the polar bear eats the blubber leaving
the meat for the fox
ideally the polar bear will catch 20
seals in just two months
but when the pack ice melts the seals
disperse and the hunting becomes lean
again
the polar bear resorts to hunting any
and everything including sled dogs
notoriously fearless polar bears were
photographed investigating a nuclear
submarine
one tried to bite the hull
searching for prey the polar bear can
swim up to 60 miles
paddling with its four legs and steering
with its hind legs
it scours the ice and rocky islands in
search of anything edible
coming up on a group of basking walruses
hunger leads it to push its luck
many of these walruses are twice a polar
bear size and their tusks are capable of
wounding or even killing a bear
[Music]
the element of surprise is key to the
bear strategy
it's caught sight of a potential meal
and fights her way through
the bears got a walrus pop
the pup's mother turns to attempt a
rescue but her defense is futile
it doesn't matter how they fight because
winners come in all shapes and sizes but
to come out on top they have to be the
best
the ultimate success stories
the ultimate predators
[Music]
you